salut bienvenue pour ce nouveau casse
tête aujourd'hui nous allons nous tapez
tapez carrément l'astrolabe riyom de
luxe la version deluxe alors je lis ce
qui a marqué sur le site tourner les
quatre disques de sorte que je ne vois
plus les disques blanc auteurs joergen
reich et on n'a pas le niveau de
difficulté donc on verra mais ça m'a pas
l'air si simple
en gros nous avons quatre disques
amovibles comme ceux ci il y en a sur
lesquels il ya des pastilles blanche
on les voit là pas en dessous de des
pastilles noires et il faut trouver la
configuration qui fait ce que ça cache
tout les pastilles blanche via
directement les pastilles noires
jusque là c'est très clair avant que la
vidéo comment sachez que cette vidéo là
existe aussi en version non monte donc
en intégralité la résolution du
casse-tête sur machines de secondaire
vous avez le lien dans la logique
ouais dans la cua [ __ ] loïc et la
description qu'ils n'écoutent rien et
bien c'est parti claude vadasz du casse
tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors l'astrolabe riyom version deluxe
et c'est vraiment j'ai craqué sur
l'objet en lui-même je trouve où je
trouve très jolie
donc je me suis dit que j'allais le
prendre et on va voir si c'est une
grosse galère aux pages vous faire voir
d'un peu plus près la haute comme ça
c'est dit le lien vers casse tête et
dans la description comme à chaque fois
et je vous fait gagner le casse tête sur
mon instagram la photo est sorti
aujourd'hui comme à chaque fois
rejoignez-moi sur un stade et en plus
ils voulaient vous participez au
concours pour le gagner donc ça se
compose d'abord d'un disque blanc qui
tourne qui ne sert à rien avec des
petits repères je pense ça peut aider
ensuite un premier disque noir et vous
voyez il ya ces gros disques lakiha au
centre mais il ya aussi les petits
disques dans l'espèce de bordure parce
que dans celui d'après c'est un autre
disque noir qui tourne
et qui a aussi des petits disques en
bordure et au centre ensuite il ya un
des premiers disques blanc qui lui aussi
comporte des petits disques blanc là
vous les voyez bouger par ici et ensuite
la même chose en dessous et enfin un
autre disque en plastique qui peut
tourner indépendamment alors tout
indépendant malheureusement je vois bien
que des fois quand jean moulin il ya un
autre qu'il bouge et c'est je pense à
battre galère c'est le genre de casse
tête qu'on peut résoudre que à tâtons au
départ donc je vais le résoudre à tâtons
et on va voir ce qui se passe à proférer
mesure donc voilà clairement par exemple
c'est pas si mal pour ceux du centre
mais c'est pas du tout bon pour l'export
en fait il faudrait que j'arrive à
dissocier dans ma tête déjà le comment
et qu'on peut comment sont composés les
disent que c est pour ça on a besoin de
quoi le hic de post-it générique post it
[Musique]
on a là mais j'ai pas de point de repère
le premier je vais faire ça pour m'aider
on a deux gros cerfs je vais pas compter
les petits pour l'instant de gros cercle
ont pour en mettre combien la plus bon
on va partir sur du tâtonnement parce
que même ça j'ai l'impression que c'est
la plus perturbée qu'autre chose mais ça
me permet de voir un peu quand même
loïc et tam et moite et de demander en
mon âme et conscience
knox julo
bon
oh oh oh
[Musique]
ou alors partir de celui qui est tout en
bas en premier sera peut-être logique
essayer de faire des couches je vais
essayer de visualiser celui dit bako
maintenant parce que celui qui est censé
directement en dessous
ils sont pas en fait ici le nâ 1 cayla
bon c'est pas du tout aller cher mais en
tout cas ça me fait dire que lui il là
il ya deux blancs à cacher sais tu t'y
fais 4 7 6 avec tous les noirs se
cachent les blancs avec tous les
blanches quel chemin du bas à butin
était pas mal à vue on ya cru un peu là
je sais pas si on peut dire que j'avance
parce que ça risque de des trucs à
tâtons peut-être je n'avance pas mais en
tout cas j'ai fait quelque chose que je
n'avais pas pardon là excusez moi je
sais en fait j'accélère toute la vidéo
parce qu'en fait fabien a décidé de ne
pas parler et de mettre sa tête devant
la caméra du convoi rien oui alors
excusez-moi je m'immisce doit-on boys
over mais peut-être que c'est exactement
là qu'on met des accélérations quand je
me parle à moi même parce que excusez
moi d'être concentré sur mon casse tête
où il met d'accord mais l'accélération
ya quand même ta tête au dessus de la
caméra donc que ça ne sert à rien on
voit rien mais s'il ya ma tête au dessus
de la caméra c'est peut-être parce que
tu ne regardes pas l'écran de retour
alors où étais-tu que regarder tu là je
regardais autre chose parce que ça
faisait neuf heures contes et des
cassettes
je commençais ça commençait à me casser
la tête pas alors sous prêter mais bon
allez
or je crois que je levais je crois que
tu peux faire chauffer la petite musique
lolo ne crions pas victoire mais quand
même
attention je contrôle non lui dépasse je
crois que c'est juste du petit réglage
de ces du petit réglage ça c'est ce que
ça se joue au millimètre en fait cette
histoire là oui c'est ça si si c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon
en fait ils se superposent donc
forcément mon angle de vue croix des
fois que ces parcs ouverts alors que si
je regarde bien par au dessus s'est
recouvert je vous fais voir ça
directement depuis les étoiles voilà
alors forcément des fois vous voyez un
peu de blanc parce qu'il faut toujours
avoir vraiment le nez dessus pour bien
voir mais on est bons casse-tête
rondement résolu à peu près une heure je
crois c'est plutôt cool je vous le mets
à gagner dans la description la version
non coupée en entier c'est sur ma chaîne
secondaire dans la description il a
gagné sur instagram bien sur instagram
vient 34 secondes à la fin de cette
vidéo pour aller sur un style vous
rajouter en plus tu vous savez pas tout
le contenu que je fais sur instagram
il ya même tous les best-of de spectacle
avec les les les impros les trucs comme
ça il ya des questions il est rempli
bon ben c'est bon à très bientôt ciao